hey this is fresh towel locker what is
the value of this mathematical
expression this map problem has gone
viral and it has received millions of
comments on Facebook Twitter YouTube and
other social media sites in this video
I'm going to present the correct answer
the problem is an example of the order
of operations these are commonly
referred to as PEMDAS or bod moss this
refers to evaluating the parentheses
brackets then the exponent orders then
multiplication and division and finally
addition subtraction if you have two
operations of the same precedence you
want to evaluate them from left to right
the first step of the problem has no
controversy this expression contains a
parenthetical expression which must be
evaluated first one plus two is inside
the parentheses so we'll evaluate 1 plus
2 to get 3 now the question is what to
do next if you input this into Google
WolframAlpha or pretty much any
scientific calculator the thing that's
going to happen next is all of these
will interpret the parentheses as an
implicit multiplication so this 2
parentheses 3 will be converted into 2
times 3 now we continue the order of
operations this expression only contains
multiplication and division these are
operators of equal precedence so we'll
evaluate them from left to right
starting on the Left we have 6 divided
by 2 6 divided by 2 is equal to 3 we
then have 3 multiplied by 3 one final
multiplication and that gets us to the
correct answer of dying this is without
a doubt the correct answer to this
expression as written according to the
modern usage of the order of operations
so why did this problem cost so much
controversy well there is another answer
that you could argue from a historical
perspective so I actually found some
documentation that the order of
operations did have a slightly different
understanding in certain text in 1917 or
before so the first part of the equation
is the same as before we have a
parenthetical expression and this should
be evaluated first we have one plus two
and that becomes three the debate then
centers around this division symbol so
what does it mean that we have six
divided by two parenthesis three while
there were textbooks and there was a lot
of usage that if you had this division
simple where he had something on the
left
divided by something on the right this
was understood to mean you want to
divide the entire product on the left by
the entire product on the right so for
example if a textbook wrote X divided by
2y with this division symbol they
actually did mean X divided by
parentheses to Y you wanted to take 2y
as the entire product and have that as
your denominator so under this
historical usage which is a special
exception to the order of operations and
we don't use it anymore you would want
to take this product on the right as
your divisor so applying this rule would
then lead to the expression six over two
x three we will now convert the
multiplication in the denominator so
that two times three is equal to six and
we now have one division which is six
divided by six and that's equal to one
so many people argue that one is the
correct answer and there is some
historical justification of this because
of the way that texts used to use the
division symbol I would suggest this is
probably because of some historical
artifact about
setting it would have been much easier
to write the division symbol and have
the understanding you want to divide
everything on the left by everything on
the right you wouldn't need to have an
expression where you write a numerator
over a denominator that would take a lot
more vertical space and you also would
need to keep putting parentheses
everywhere this would be just something
that would be understood today we don't
use this practice because it can be
confusing
instead we follow the order of
operations if we want to have a fraction
we will put it as an expression like 6
over 6 which is written here so the
correct answer to this problem is 9 but
there is some historical justification
for the answer 1 but it's not how we
would interpret the problem today did
you get to the correct answer of 9
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Locker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description